Isabel Montenegro vive en Santa Cruz
donde el dengue está causando estragos
para combatirlo participa en una jornada
comunitaria de limpieza eliminando los
recipientes con agua donde anida el
mosquito transmisor a edesagy todo eso
que es criadero de mosquito y que no se
puede reutilizar porque ya está muy
oxidado muy viejo lo estamos llevando
para que se lo lleve el camión de la
minga hace poco la enfermedad llegó a su
hogar le dio a mi hijito a uno de 9 años
hace unas tres semanas atrás 7 días
estuvo delicado los hospitales súper
saturados ahora Isabel ha redoblado sus
esfuerzos para sacar las botellas de
casa los funcionarios han fumigado
varios barrios de Santa Cruz y cargados
toda la basura
para responder a la saturación de los
hospitales un centro de campaña recibe a
los enfermos en carpas Así que ahorita
me lo van a internar aquí el hospital al
aire libre que fue donado por Estados
Unidos se ha convertido en una opción
para las familias que buscan ayuda de
forma desesperada son hospitales de
campaña en el país para poder responder
a emergencias y desastres en el hospital
del niño muchas mamás rezan por la
recuperación de sus hijos
la principal dirigente de los médicos
acusa a las autoridades de negligencia
por la muerte de los niños
el dengue en sí como enfermedad si
estuviera pasado en otra parte del mundo
donde un sistema no estuviera colapsado
un sistema de salud no hubiera habido
tanta mortalidad
acciones preventivas como las de Isabel
y las limpiezas colectivas son
importantes para contener la enfermedad
que ya deja más de 40 muertos sin
embargo por más que se eliminen los
criaderos de mosquitos en Santa Cruz
nada Parece ser suficiente contra la
epidemia